so you said you definitely loved working
with youtubers because they were
professional they were grateful to be on
set they knew their lines i'm suing in
the answer is yes that you would use
them again in your next project
absolutely there I'm so impressed of so
many levels I mean they're little
struggle they're rock stars you know
they're really I'm so inspired by that
the dead halt occurrence that really
didn't exist five years ago called a
youtuber you know and again they're
awesome no great actors with
collaborators of great personalities
charismatic and if you think about it
all that and the account they really
wouldn't be able to to have those jobs
on youtube because they do support
themselves by doing right and do you
think that their notoriety has really
helps your film along the roadside
because sometimes you see when other
actors they're so busy doing other stuff
and they're not you're really used to
being on social media the way youtubers
are mm-hmm it's sort of all part of the
package yeah I would love for this young
to be referred to as a YouTube movie
that's the one where youtubers got in
and I would love for this song to be it
you know then the one where the cross
happened or it started or we kind of you
know dipped our toes in the water I'm
ready they like cannonball for the next
selling you know like get everyone you
know I'll put him with Tom Cruise in the
movie that would be a mix you know but
out um yeah I think it's I think there I
don't know I mean they know what they're
doing you know did they know what it's
developing a real like meaningful
relationship with their audience I think
they have that they have established
that they know how to do that and tan
today is an indie filmmaker who makes
little film with heart the only you know
desire I have
from iphone to be seen by as many people
as possible because I do believe a lot
of them will really enjoy it and again
there's so many great people and I
always get bogged down when I discovered
them and I'm like how how how did I know
about this movie you know and I look up
it was mainly 97 or I was like years ago
it's like this is what happens there's
so many great films out there and so
even buried and I hope they don't remain
buried but it's the reality there's so
many great films and they're buried and
I don't want this one to be varied and I
want anybody else Mary but i think would
youtubers at least their audience or
nobody which could be enough what did
you learn from Iman Chris on and the
other youtubers in terms of how they
approach things or what was something
that was interesting that you learned
that they all kind of had with them they
aren't the same tree mm-hmm uh
discipline like him I never that's fun
he might never complained during the
shift now that was awesome him because
he was really hard like shooting a hotel
with on our budget but you didn't exist
was pretty hard you know so you know you
have Iman who's there I don't know as if
he's going to trailer a favor take being
you know in hair makeup like none of
that but he was there just top of his
game and then in the editing and that
was funny editing are going to takes and
as one of the shots where the camera is
a you know connected the car with with
the hood mount and they're just driving
and the labs were on and then we hear
the dialogue before then we were started
I mean before they take started but the
camera was rolling and the sound was
recording it is like I'm tired
oh so he was fearless yeah we gotta go
if you eat to keep it to yourself you
know because i think if it's public then
he gets on everybody's skin you know but
uh I mean I would you know blowing brain
pretty much twice a day you know but I
guess you go in with that and filmmaking
is is that's what it is it's some for me
at least it's one it's that time of year
when you're supposed to beat yourself to
the ground and try to you know come up
and if you were smooth and felt like a
massage then I don't know like did you
make a movie you know I forget whose
quota was what they said making a film
it's just it's like everything's falling
apart and it's your job to keep it from
totally tanking yeah I had this whole
thing you know by reality I'm like okay
making a movie we're creating in your
reality for messing with time and space
and I think reality kind of knows what
we're trying to do and is attentional II
intentionally messing with us like you
want to make reality all right watch
this clouds you know cop here you know
hot day here and stuff like that a
person with the baby crosses no you know
and we throws all these darts at you and
you have to take it as a game as it you
know with you in reality that's how I
approach it's a bit nuts but it gets me
through the day do you think reality
ever lets you graduate and they go all
right we've put zorn through enough
let's let's let them haha or no it's no
I don't think so yeah I don't think so
every day there's something that pisses
me off you know and i think it's an over
you know ongoing thing
you